huge news for the kardashians indeed
surprise courtney and travis barker said
i do in las vegas whoa
it just comes natural it's like a
maturity thing travis and i want to have
a baby
and a half hours after drumming for her
and lenny kravitz at the grammys travis
tied the knot with court in a secret
ceremony it was just down the strip at
this wedding chapel at 1 40 a.m what
were they wearing the same office they
had on at the watch show
one love wedding chapel owner marty
fryerson took us inside they said vows
elvis officiated them and they kissed
and
loved and danced they probably kissed
all the way out the door
it's unclear though if the ceremony is
legally binding we checked clark county
records and found no marriage license
application momager chris tells ellen
today the couple's pda is pretty out
there on the family's new hulu show
which premieres april 14th travis and
courtney for real just make out nonstop
that's all they do well it is 98 of the
new show is that wrong
also featured kim's divorce from kanye
it is really hard with kanye he told me
my career is over a source tells e.t kim
has moved on for real though who are you
texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
kim has found new love pete's great
pete's great he's a really nice guy he
just makes her laugh and she laughs all
the time pete davidson gets the
kardashian seal of approval in this
exclusive preview of the abc news
special the kardashians which airs
tomorrow how serious is it
i mean i am a
like relationship kind of girl for sure
and i wouldn't be with someone if i
didn't plan on spending a lot of my time
with them obviously i want to take my
time but i'm very happy and very content
and it's such a good feeling just to be
at peace
you